how do you follow a character's journey
through their emotion and not through
plot points
okay well a lot of that has to do with
your
you know obviously your
when you're figuring out what you want
to say
and i think it depends on your you know
you're doing um
tv film
you know with a film you obviously have
a major dramatic question they're going
to answer that by the end either they're
going to get what they want or they
don't get what they want
and in television you're obviously doing
it over a longer stretch of time and
there may be mechanisms if you're doing
streaming versus
you know broadcast either you want that
person to have to learn that lesson over
and over and over again on the comedy
side or on the drama side it's going to
be a week to week if you're going to
keep doing the same thing essentially
right
and then on the uh on the streaming side
sometimes there is an endpoint right
look at queen's gambit there's a there's
a feature structure underneath that and
so
you know she gets to the end of the
of her want
so
um but when you're figuring out what the
character you know you need to figure
out who your character is for me what i
do uh as a practice is i do a character
aria
which is and i think other people have
different you know ways of talking about
this i actually heard um you know i
think the screenwriting life has a
podcast megalophobe and uh lauren
mckenna do this whole thing about um
and they think they call it arya but
they do it song you know what is that
your character singing of that want for
me i always called it an and arya from
way back which is just
on on a on a single page i just do a
monologue where the character is
yelling at someone the antagonist about
what they want and why they want it and
it helps me focus and i think it's it
was a practice that i always did for my
for my fellows
it helped them focus on
how that character moved in the world
what do they sound like so do they have
a dialect do they have a southern drawl
whatever that is
um
and then what is it that they want and
why do they want it and how do they plan
to get it
and i think that when you are able to
focus that character
you may or may not ever use that i think
oh usually at some point usually in a
movie it comes you know at the low point
somewhere there's a a
a moment where they
lay it all out there you know i just
want this and sometimes that want has
changed but there's always a i just want
this thing
um
and obviously they need to know in the
beginning but that thing sometimes this
thing usually changes over time
but you want that character
to be so clear in their goal that
there's no mistaking that that's
what the want is
and usually in like a procedural it's i
want to catch the bad guy
so i'm going to make then all these
steps and quite honestly quite
it it does help if you go i need to do x
y and z in order to get there that way
we as an audience know oh that's what
we're on the ride for we know what's
going to happen i need to get the
package from point a to point b then i
go i know what i'm looking at
so but finding out that characters want
and really understanding that
character's want is is key and then
emotion the emotional part underneath it
is is the why why do i want it you know
i want the the
the um
the promotion
i don't know that anybody cares about
you wanting a promotion i want the
promotion because i'm going to win my
wife back
then i care
if that character's
thing that they want so much is
motivated emotionally
that woman is the only one who
understands me or i screwed up and i
need to get her back or you know that
underpinning of the
of the emotion is going to drive and
keep us on the road
for the entire
length of that
episode series or whatever it is
so i do think that those are important
really key
drivers for your you know otherwise
there's no story
it's you know it's all about the story
why is the emotional truth so important
in the writing process
what my pr my own personal emotional
truth or any writer yeah any writer
whether it's you critiquing another
writer for yourself well i think i i
actually think we sort of talked a
little bit about this already which is
you know
the the more honest the more authentic
the
um the writing
the more truthful it is the more it
resonates it just bumps up like crazy
and you can tell when someone's willing
to give that and when someone's hedging
their bets
so i do think that that's
that's how we
understand each other
as if you're giving as much of your
emotional truth as you possibly can
right
yeah we've all read books where it's an
autobiography
and some seem a little rosier maybe or
their intentions seem a little rosier
than
maybe what the situation turned out to
be sure we can always kind of feel like
okay i feel like i'm not getting the
real story or i'm getting like a pr
version right i read one recently that's
a pretty big one
that is out right now and i went i'm not
buying it like i just thought it felt
really manufactured
and
and it was unsettling because i thought
well there's some real story there that
i'm not knowing and they're not allowing
me in they're giving me the sanitized
version so you could tell you could tell
when a i don't know if you could tell of
a ghostwriter but you can tell someone
else's
when someone else is when someone is not
really being 100
and then that's not really a very
satisfying book is it
right unless it's it's it's a show of
someone who's maybe somewhat delusional
not not like crazy no but really in in
terms of
why they did something their intentions
and think seeing themselves i mean
everybody sees themselves as a hero and
that's just how it is so but but
sort of like the way they would convince
themselves that they did the right thing
and it really wasn't so
you're kind of seeing this character
that's very broken but um but i think in
in many cases yeah if it's let's say a
business leader or whatever and they're
writing this thing where they tried
their hardest and it was really because
they wanted for the greater good and
you're seeing through that
then it is hard to right okay
yeah no give me the give me the real
give me the
the broken messy part that's the more
interesting part
how often as an executive would you read
a screenplay that would make you cry
well as you can tell i'm a big crier so
i um
uh i'm not going to say i
read a ton of them
that would make me cry but remember many
times i was in the comedy department
so i spent a huge chunk of my career
doing the comedy thing and then um
but i someone asked on twitter recently
they said what's the like the best
script that you've read as a from a
newbie
and there was a
script
that a couple of
writers
a team of writers had
written
after a very fraught development
uh period where they had not been
entirely truthful about their
intentions they were trying to do things
that would sell as opposed to things
that they loved
and at a certain point i don't think
they were going to mind that that i
tell this story
but at a certain point i pulled them
aside it was towards the end of the
program and i said
okay what's going on here i go because
this isn't working and they were trying
to do something really sci-fi like well
we thought you know
we could
you know they're not that many writers
who look like us in sci-fi and we
thought we could sort of basically
they're trying to game the system right
and
and i said well
this is feels like a matchup between
hunger games and game of thrones and you
know something else thrown in there
he said so what is your favorite show
and they said this is us
and i said then you have to write your
version of this as us
and
i'm gonna say a couple weeks later they
delivered a script
that knocked my socks off and i was
sobbing at the end of page one and by
the end of page three i was just a
puddle and a co-worker walked by i was i
was in the office super early it was
like seven in the morning
my co-worker walked by
and uh
and stopped and said are you okay and i
was like no it's a really good script
and i was
wrecked and it's still probably one of
the best scripts i've read to this day
it's just and these
the the pair had just rolled out of
college had just rolled out of
nyu
dramatic i think dramatic art school we
live in the drama program
and i think that's why i say that
there's there's talent everywhere
you know we
we ended up getting another there was
another team of the
this i think the season before
um i want to say maybe 2015
again they just come out of college
so age is not a factor obviously i'm
making a career and i'm in my 50s late
50s
so age is not a factor
when you think about the talent that's
out there
and when you get people who are
so willing to again be emotional and
and be truthful
there's you can feel them on the page in
this script
then it just is undeniable
so
you know and then i will also say i also
read scripts
that i read a lot of scripts of things
that have already been produced that i
know have made me cry and i just want to
see well how did they do it so my own
process is i read a ton of scripts even
now
i usually put them up on scriptation i
think it is the app
and i go and i circle things and i let
go this is a really cool way of doing
something or i love this turn of phrase
and does this feel like it's something
that i can kind of use or i love the
formatting in this and this is how they
made the action go faster and you know
this is how they use their dashes or
their
you know their introductions and and i
learn from other people and other
writers
so and hopefully implement some of that
juicy goodness into my own scripts
but uh but i would say i could probably
count
on one hand the number of scripts that
have made me
cry
but that doesn't mean that i haven't
been moved
and i've been moved quite a bit by
people's honesty
and their willingness to go there